[Music]
what do you call banks again with one
leg shorter than the other right so in
another episode of celebrities try to do
good but get backlash oh man this is
your favorite news you guys remember
Angie's come out it's like that daenerys
targaryen [ __ ] gifs that you've seen
or the image you seen of like it's like
white people during these crisis like a
bunch of people are reaching for that of
Daenerys because she's so that's how
they feel well they call that like
extreme virtual signalling yeah exactly
as you guys all might remember a few
months ago and the beginning of this
whole pandemic started gal gadot I don't
whole bunch of her rich celebrity
friends - all singing imagine fixed a
lot of stuff it was a nice song I was
mad she made me cringe it hurt so hard
because she's so pretty I'll still see
that new Wonder Woman on you oh it's
gonna be great
do you ever crying so hard you just like
literally have to just like throw your
phone down yeah I feel moments of cringe
so hard where I feel like like the
cringe is coming out of my pores when
you watch the imagine video not that one
but it's like that one got me a little
bit but like watching the stuff that's
coming out now I'm just like with Tim
and Nicki do puns I think you know what
gave me some really weird feelings um
don't mess with the Zohan they made you
cringe yeah just some of it would just
seem so lean weird the poster baby grin
like he was like frying a fish and then
he throws it in the air he lays on the
ground it catches with his butt cheeks
Oh actually I'm just like what like you
don't get art you're in the wrong part
I'm like what is going on the wood sorry
dude I'm a big fan of Adam sand on the
way why is he making movies like this
maybe he saw Mike Myers and then he was
like that's what I should be doing yeah
this just his butt cheeks
what was that Mike Myers movie that came
after Austin Powers and no one likes
cava
I haven't seen it like it I was a kid
when I want to do it Oh watch your
recent I watched it recently it was kind
of weird - you're the first person that
men who liked it that's cool but I like
different kind of thoughts and stuff
that's cool no
you're wrong probably just like enough
oh [ __ ] okay well so now you respect him
for his trash ass Youth ass oh I'll
never appreciate that you like can't
have loving can the hell you're like I
cannot respect your opinions from here
on I want to see it I've seen it what
can that that's why I would like to
these but only because of the nostalgia
reasons anyway now we're talking you
just you you like you didn't stick to
your guns
what do you mean I love that movie then
it could literally tell you every lie
tell me what happening line the opening
line is one day here in small or just
kidding matter no the opening line is
brought to you by Columbia Pictures
Johnny goes yeah baby all those famous
actors no that's cats that one kill
anyway we're talking about the newest
celebrity cringe here oh so they all
partnered up they got together to take
part in I take responsibility campaign
okay
all the white people that is where all
these celebrities they partnered with
the n-double-a-cp
to get white people to recognize their
own harmful actions and take a stand
against them
and so they created this PSA where the
majority of the internet is saying this
is [ __ ] cringy stop doing this
celebrities rich celebrities yeah
exactly but I don't know I personally
I'm like I'm like hey dude could they
try it wrong there I say the same thing
the intention of their here we go it's
not take responsibility take
responsibility is the music really not
terrible and black and white it's trying
too hard
Kristen Bell what it was everyone so
funny joke every blatant injustice no
matter how big or small every time I
remain silent
every time I explained away police
brutality black people are being
slaughtered in the streets
killed in their own
these are brothers and sisters we are
done watching them die I don't even know
half of them we are no longer bystanders
we will not be idle I will no longer
allow that guys chase stir it damn that
one guy when they're coming or swarm to
the other in my presence going for a jog
should not be a death sentence sleeping
in your own home should not be a death
sentence oh I think I see why the
history if your nephew should not be a
dentist I don't even know she owns in a
store should not be a death sentence I
stand against hate I stand against hate
I stand against hate I will stand
against hate and killer cops must be
prosecuted they are murdered Jessie
pitch [ __ ] [ __ ] it's time
go sell method a responsible I can't
appreciate what they're trying to do
step up but he's so close to touching
his own penis while he says it I get why
that's cream gee I'm pretty sure it's
like it's the fact that it's so scripted
and so like dramatic music black and
white it makes you feel like it makes it
feel not genuine because it's so put
together yeah I'm just like okay if you
want to just do it don't ya have to make
it because the words are good what
they're saying is like these are good
you know these are good things they're
saying but I think right when I saw
Aaron Paul that when he came I I just
seemed so like acting like they had to
be sad yeah well Jenna you know just
like well Walter why just yelled at him
sure his girlfriend did overdose yeah
but it's like you can tell that it's
like obviously it's this critically
learners are the same thing
well this format happens every time is
it we all agree agree I think this I
think it's time it's time it's time it's
so [ __ ] boring like this so someone
on Twitter said named kaya Jones I don't
know she is but she has a verification
mark anyway she said there's actually
nothing we're racists and then saying
what you are saying insinuating black
people need white saviors I'm biracial
and I don't see black or white but human
beings maybe if you just supported each
other instead of this savior narrative
we might actually get somewhere but how
do you guys explain this so I don't know
if you've been a part of it but I've
been a part of a couple like the Asian
American voting campaign things which is
kind of like that
so when they're putting it together it's
like usually one organization try to
make movement happen with the people
right so it's I don't know if they
self-assembled or if it's and
double-a-c-p reaching out to like I
don't know management group I want to
get this many people this many more
signups or whatever so it's what we're
seeing is like what's on the surface and
we're not seeing like the driving forces
behind it I've been a part of some
voting ones we're trying to get more
Asian Americans to focus just agent
Americans don't didn't vote that much
back then and until like me and Joe or
like telling people to go forward and
they cut a bunch of us together like all
Volvo koval and I feel like it could be
cringy too I mean the subject matter is
definitely way lighter than this for
sure but I also see that it's another or
is just an aura this is just kind of
like the method of how they're trying to
get more people to go do something or
have a movement if you guys are other
people are this organization what other
ways that they do it if they're not
tapping into people with big followings
or recognizable faces you know well I
think like Dave Chappelle said the
streets are speaking and when these guys
say this [ __ ] everyone doesn't really
necessarily want to hear from them I
don't need to hear Aaron Paul sues but
he was telling us he Pinkman
it was just way that he was still jessic
people yeah you would I wanted to hear
Aaron Paul but it's like you're still
Jesse pink the aggressiveness and his
toe yeah are you Jesse like it's
different when it's like hey everybody
vote like yeah okay that makes more
sense if we're all saying go vote but
then like for something for this subject
matter to have them all say this
pre-written thing and then have them
like and some of them are like hardcore
acting it into camp it's so corny oh
yeah it just comes off like ah this
doesn't feel trying to sell me hard and
it's like they definitely reached out
because it's like if they didn't they
would have had other people than just
white people like trying to like well
the whole point was was like we're white
and we're trying ya know it's like we're
white and we recognize the subtle racist
things that we have let let it slip by
in the past or whatever it's more like
I'm taking responsibility for what I
could do in my
where I'm like that's their basis
they're like oh no longer laugh at those
jokes when you guys say that very or
know you like I'm gonna move I'm gonna
point out how racist that is now and not
be okay with it not let it be part of
the culture anymore they're tripping
over each other to say I care I care I
care so much in next life is like I and
that's why people have an issue with it
because they feel like them doing that
it's putting the attention back on them
and it seems like okay it's like they're
taking the attention away from like the
actual problem and the struggle and
being like hey guys I'm gonna try it and
it feels like they're asking for
attention for helping or China know I
can for sure I see that angle but then I
also I'm trying to like see it from like
the celebrities angle where there's so
many people are yelling at them and
screaming like you haven't said [ __ ]
you're not doing [ __ ] which I'm like
yeah you should be out there signing
petitions and donating your money to
organizations that are fighting the good
fight but I mean this is kind of like
their attempt of being like see we're
trying to do something cuz a lot of
these guys probably are doing things
already you know like I've done it to a
bunch of the charities that were in that
list and not one square
I don't publicize it you don't need you
don't need to you know but then there's
also but it is also okay but then
there's also people that almost like oh
if you don't publicize them and you
didn't do it oh my god of things I've
done my personal and I don't want to
share with other people so there's a lot
of loud people like that that I think
maybe it's like making them kind of like
silenced the people that are like I'm
not doing [ __ ] you never know how cringy
and bad it is until you do it yeah
that's true I think it's like with like
what Steve was saying they do this so
often and it's like the same thing where
it's kind of like okay like this isn't
really gonna change much if you just say
maybe they could just maybe post by this
was I'll talk how they would normally
talk but they're all trying to do the
same one they had the same script
they're doing all these different things
but all the same things and it just
seems like okay now we're done you know
I think yeah the script part is what
kills it it would have been a
compilation of everybody saying a little
short statement of maybe how they feel
and they're not influencers they're
actors I mean the nation part of this
group should have been and I'm donating
this much
yeah it's something that actually helped
or just say something from the heart
genuine yeah like those that you mean I
like when the Imagine came out they had
like John Mayer was like hey guys so
like they actually hit me up to be a
part of it but then didn't really tell
me like the full details are you crest
that imagine by ariana grande so he cut
in
he drew like they're nice enough to send
me back the edit so it's everyone's
singing and then he pops in oh happy
seeing that Ariana but comedians now are
taking this video and inserting
themselves saying random [ __ ] it's like
[ __ ] funny you know it I get it you
know it's tough because it's like you
know you feel like damned if you do
damned if you don't know oh yeah but I
also see why this is cringy I mean has
it affected other people to own up like
I don't know like other white people
that let you up guilty as charged
yeah exactly they do this every year
though man like they did this I remember
in the election in 2016 they'd had every
cast member of the every who's ever in
an Avengers movie do all this [ __ ] to go
vote and nobody [ __ ] care
you still had like the same amount of
people voted like like maybe a little
bit more than last time like it's always
like more people stay at home and go
vote so it's just what Steve it's what
the effort whoa in the replies of
Julianne Moore's video and on Twitter
there's this you called it that's what
it looks like and they're like we're
look at us look up at us Oh tilt your
head
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]